martin biron à la castonguay stéphanie
grammond bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir on en a
parlé au tout début de l'émission j'en
ai parlé avec sébastien aussi un peu de
ce rapport de la coroner kamel elle vole
là où peut-être on l'attendait pas
nécessairement tour de table mais je
vous montre juste avant mesdames et
messieurs les recommandations trois
principales santé publique indépendante
fin des seiches celle des privés et
implanter des ratios soins résidents
sécuritaire ce que ça veut dire en clair
plus de personnel dans les sièges celle
des si on vous a pas dit sort au moins
mille fois on vous l'a pas dit une fois
martin premiers commentaires sur ce
rapport et et les aciers le jeu envers
la ministre blais indien elle a fait ce
qu'elle a pu et elle était quand même
relativement clair devant moi un martyr
et elle ne blâme pas vraiment le
politique elle blâme plutôt la machine
je dirais dont des directeurs des pdg de
sus mais aussi les médecins elle est
plutôt au tolérante à l'égard du pouvoir
politique effectivement mais faisait
qu'elles arrivent quatrièmes après la
vérificatrice générale et protectrice du
citoyen la commissaire la santé 2
excellent livre de alec castonguay des
journalistes de la presse alors donc le
dossier est assez documenté on sait que
eu des ratés des ratés important mais
c'est clair les âmes la plupart des
conclusions démontrent que le système de
santé était dans un état pitoyable
alors elle libère marguerite blais
essentiellement parce qu'elle a
collaboré et elle a levé le drapeau
rouge en dix ans les sièges s'est dit
vous êtes en train de les oublier mais
le niveau de pouvoir de marguerite blais
il était pas si élevé que ça c'est le
ministre délégué un ministre délégué n'a
pas de
de budget c'est en fait un adjoint si
vous voulez au ministre au ministre de
la santé alors la balle va plus dans le
cas de daniel mais kahn qui était
ministre de la santé et membre de la
cellule de crise ll a choisi la
coronaire kamel
de deux peuples amis la cellule de crise
alors c'est vraiment un choix exactement
de ne pas blâmer le politique comme vous
dites bien oui ici et là mais alec
qu'est ce qui ressort selon vous de sa
belle se dit que j'aimais le relais ou
quand même qu'il ya eu au niveau
politique la confusion plus visiblement
une peau n'est pas vraiment culte
témoignage de daniel mais cannes qui en
disait dès la fin janvier j'ai demandé
aussi aux sus de préparer les 6h et
celle des alat la directive qui avaient
été envoyées tout sauf claire elle dit
non je te pose ce n'est pas très clair
mais elle va pas plus loin que saint
martin a raison cela dit qui est après
ça s'est beaucoup des circonstances
qu'on connaît quand est-ce qu'on a
commandé des équipements de protection
individuelle trop tard on était mal
préparé son le savez donc on retrace un
peu le
la génèse de cette catastrophe l'homme
mais pas avec de nouveaux avec des
nouveautés par rapport à ce que les
autres comme sarah la santé
vérificatrice générale d'une protection
citoyens aux sorties dont que rien à ses
recommandations là je pense avec
lesquels le gouvernement khakis ne peut
pas vivre au contraire des choses là
dedans je pense qu'ils sont déjà dans
les cartons je pense le promeut le
prochain directeur
national de santé publique sera
indépendant je pense qu'on est déjà
rendu l'âme et comme celui qui a été
nominé par intérim on over on n'avait
pas besoin de faire ça maintenant le
prochain vont probablement life je pense
qu'au gouvernement aussi riches de l'ue
à ce type de décision là les prix
blessés chez celles des 100 % privé ça
tire à sa fin aussi pas mal écrit dans
le ciel pour retrouver de manière mais
accords part aux services publics dès
lors on peut descendre des
recommandations y ont rien qui donne
beaucoup de munitions aux partis
d'opposition et ancien de réflexion
politique c'est ce qu'on voulait voir la
campagne électorale approche est ce que
ça va être une bombe ce que ça vaut
saute au visage du gouvernement qu'à qui
sait ça va relancer le débat il n'y a
pas grand chose là dedans avec
lesquelles l'opposition pour faire du
millage une ou deux périodes de
questions je pense pas qu'on ait
nécessairement c'est le rapport on
aurait souhaité disposer du parti
stéphanie elle aurait pu recommander
elle en parle mais c'est vraiment une
phrase qui permet toute la latitude au
gouvernement d' il devrait avoir un
examen une rétrospective de fermer
faites ce que vous voulez puis je vous
dit rien alors ceux qui voulaient une
commission d'enquêté publique je pense
que c'est terminé là c'est fait nous
soyons clairs de toute façon on pourrait
en parler le de façon serrée tant qu'on
voudra la réalité c'est que la cac elle
n'en fera pas de commission donc je
pense que l'heure ce qui est intéressant
se dit ok maintenant au west qu'on en
est rendu et est-ce qu'on peut regarder
en avant parce que quand on regarde en
arrière avec ce rapport le ce qu'on voit
c'est oui il ya eu une crise
épouvantable dans les ch et celle des
mais ça faisait des années que les
problèmes perdurent et et que y auriez
qui se faisait le pauvre pour rémédier
au problème et quand on lit le rapport
de la vérificatrice générale qui est
sorti il ya quelques jours à peine ce
qu'on constate c'est qu'il ya toujours
oreiller pour régler les problèmes donc
en ch et celle des le dans tout ce qui
est soins de longue durée mais il n'y a
pas assez de place pour héberger tout le
monde en ce moment et le gouvernement
n'ont pas de plan pour voir revenir leur
prix la croissance démographique
vainqueur et c'est comme un paquebot
l'on voit souvenir de loin mais on
n'agit pas et les maisons des aînés qui
sont faits en projet ça va à peine
réussir à combler la liste d'attenté en
ce moment qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec
tous les bébés boumeurs qui s'en
viennent fait qu'ils vont prendre de
l'âge a peut-être des soins à domicile
c'est sûr que c'est une très bonne piste
mais encore là on est très très très
loin de combler les besoins actuels et
donc c'est pas une façon de dire bon
mais on va abandonner les gens à leur
sens chez eux il faut aussi on veut
faire savoir ce virage là il faut un
plan il faut de l'argent puis en ce
moment il n'y a aucun plan de rattrapage
qui est fait moi c'est ce que je pense
que c'est bien sûr qu'on doit s'attaquer
mai et le dire d'autres mots ce que vous
dites là bon la tempête qui nous a
frappés n'a fait que mettre en lumière
les faiblesses structurelles jeunes du
réseau 1 qui est à bout de souffle mais
une réflexion sociétale doit s amorcer
lol des projets pas juste du béton des
belles maisons mais il faut pas juste
parler des soins de mission quelquefois
très bien alors voilà pour le rapport
kamel la manifestation en fin de semaine
on va voir des images à montréal
d'anglophones oui mais il y avait des
francophones avaient déjà qui trouve
qu'avec le projet de loi 96 le
gouvernement devient deviendra tatillon
à certains endroits dans le domaine du
travail ou
vos restreignent trop inutilement trop
de place dans les cégeps anglophones on
va écouter madame anglade qui était la
manifestation pompiers
c'était important de montrer notre appui
à la communauté puis le premier message
qu'on doit lancer c'est que on dit très
conscient de l'importance de la langue
française l'importance de la protection
des dépenses dans la promotion mais il
faut qu'on fasse de manière inclusive il
faut qu'on fasse pour tous les québécois
et en ce sens le projet de loi 96 ne
répond pas à ces objectifs là
bon alors martin certains ont dit c'est
une erreur
certains ont même écrit un geste de
désespoir pour madame anglais madame
anglade est venu dire des choses là
dedans qu'on n'aime pas comment vous
avez vu cette participation là je pense
que madame anglade revient à sa
clientèle traditionnelle depuis
l'élection partielle de marie victorin
il ya quelque chose qui s'est passé chez
les libéraux on a vraiment pris
conscience que le virage à gauche de
madame anglade ça marchait pas et
qu'elle s'en allait vers un mur s'il
continuait de ce côté là il la clé comme
sa clientèle traditionnelle est fâché
contre elle essentiellement parce que
ils n'auront pas ils ont pas tenu compte
de leurs positions notamment sur la loi
96 mais également ceux concernant le
collège dawson alors là elle revient à
sa clientèle puis elle veut à certains
égards sauver les meubles sauver les
circonscriptions qu'elle veut garder
halak sur le fond je pense vous la
vienne entrevue ce midi un bangladais
dit limiter le nombre de francophones
qui vont d'un cégep anglophone c'est pas
une bonne idée est ce qu'elle a répondu
sur ces questions là est plus clair
depuis quelques semaines parce que sur
nos positions projet de loi et étaient
passibles r au début disons cela comme
ça ouais ça en fait ces changements de
cap qui fait mal à dominique anglade
parce qu'elle avait bien accueilli le
projet de loi semblait vouloir
travailler avec simon jeune un parent
est parce que le déclin du français à
montréal et véritable et loeb et on a
l'impression que pour des raisons
tactiques politiques le parti libéral
d'hubert voté contre puis on va
participer à des manifestations alors
que des problèmes dans ce projet de loi
là ce qui est un peu dérangeant du
produit de la taxe et qu'on en a fait
sonner contre projet loi 96 sur les
contres langue française dont les
comptes sa protection alors que des
choses je pense par exemple obliger les
réfugiés qui arrivent d'un pays en
guerre a parlé france en six mois que
peu de bon sens les pouvoirs accordés à
l'artiste québécoise de langue française
du droit de pétition pour les fouiller
dans des ordinateurs sa peau de bon sens
non plus mais c'est inscrit dans le
projet de loi il y aurait des choses à
corriger dans ce projet de loi l'homme
et on en effet un espèce de jusqu'au
boutisme du côté du gouvernement il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont adhéré à cette
fête c'est compliqué pour le parti
libéral de ce rock positionné attraits
de la mort bien accueilli cc oui à des
pressions de la communauté anglophone
que des partis politiques qui se crée
qui vont jouer dans les platebandes
parti libéral qui les forcent
probablement ce changement de cap le
mais comme ça à la plus ou moins
sincères ou sans l'air d'être un peu
arrangé à la dernière minute avant des
élections on en paie un prix politique
qui est important les anglophones vont
trouver tel arrive très tard dans le
débat les francophones vont penser
qu'ils allaient contre le projet de loi
est donc contre la protection du
français ce que c'est ça qu'on qu'on
martèle depuis maintenant des mois du
côté du gouvernement donc c'est une
position très très grave que le parti
libéral actuellement
de prendre stéphanie du êtes vous du
même avis qu'il y aurait peut-être fallu
que dès le début elles soient plus
claires ou en tout cas plus didactique
sur ce qui allait ce qu'elle est pas
dans ce projet de loi mais c'est sûr que
là on a un peu l'impression que c'est la
girouette au parti libéral sur cet enjeu
l'heure parce que sinon ce sont ces
mêmes en arrière avant même le dépôt du
projet de loi 96 les libéraux font c'est
pour avoir des avancées ce sont eux
mêmes qui est qu'ils ont dit un oui ça
serait bien d'appliquer sa aux
entreprises de plus petite taille et
finalement françois legault a ajouté
ajouté sur le temps donc moi
personnellement je souhaite à ce moment
là elle quand le projet a été déposé je
me disais peut-être aura-t-on un
finalement belle conjointe belle
conjoncture les a souvent être aligné un
temps au fédéral où on voyait qu'il y
avait aussi un projet de loi qui ont été
déposées pour là pour préserver le
français que ici au québec où on voyait
que même les partis d'opposition se
positionnait pour justement la défense
du français oui évidemment on est tous
pour la protection du français c'est sûr
et certain mais le débat s'est pris une
tournure très divisive et les libéraux
se sont cherchés à travers ça ils
reviennent maintenant une position plus
historique pour eux si je peux le dire
on l'a vu avec michel seyt la cour la
semaine dernière qui est revenu en se
présentant le temps autrement mont royal
avec une position beaucoup plus ferme
non mais non madame anglade mais sauf
que l'impression que ça donne c'est
qu'ils savent pas nécessairement dans
quelle direction
avec tout ça bon et l'impression que ça
donne c'est que on peut difficilement
être compte certains éléments du projet
de loi 96 sans être taxé comme j'ai dit
à l'aigle soit pas de vrais québécois ou
pas de nationalisme avour comprenez rien
et étonnement quand j'ai vu c'est oui du
chef de cabinet du premier ministre qui
est quand même la personne la plus
proche de monsieur legault qui au fil
stéphanie je vais vous laisser le temps
qui faute de répondre mais je vais vous
montrer les twin mesdames et messieurs
ça puisse paraître des modes arcade mais
ça n'est pas parce que ça révèle
d'autres shows j'adore lire des
quotidiens des magazines écrit-il il
dessine un portrait en temps réel de
notre époque j'ai une observation
l'égard de la presse plus qui m'habite
depuis un bon moment suite ce sera
pareil en a trois j'ai souvent
l'impression que les chroniqueurs et les
histoires réalistes de la presse sont
interchangeables
ils pourraient tous signé les textes de
leurs collègues sans accrochage ou
désaccord et puis conclusion est ce
possible que la presse plus est atteint
inconsciemment du net atteint concernant
une forme de groupes kings une pensée de
groupe qui aplanit la diversité des
idées ça peut arriver à tout le monde
inutile de soulever ces questions belle
et utile ici à ceux des bottes de poser
la question est il approprié qu'un chef
de cabinet
s'adresse à un des deux groupes
importants à deux entrepôts de dessins
et donc à vous mais je vais vous donner
la parole en dernier c'est fanny martin
sur le chef de quelques astuces est sa
job de faire ça que parasite est malsain
dans le débat public ces pistes et pas
n'importe quel chef de cabinet c'est
quand même un des hommes les plus
puissants du québec c'est le bras droit
depuis plusieurs années de françois
legault quand on téléphone sonne c'est
martin koskinen qui est lot tu réponds
et il ya eu cette capacité d'appeler
soit stéphanie ou n'importe quel
directeur de l'organisation presse et il
a la certitude que cette personne ne va
prendre la pelle et pour être entendu il
ya un petit côté signature cap qu'ici et
c'est pas le seul
conseiller important de monsieur legault
qui qui se laissent aller à des tweets
quand ils sont pas très satisfaits de
souad d'une chronique que soient
développés
même à l'égard de l'adversaire vous je
vous prie se plaît ici c'est jean-luc
devrait s'élever davantage quand le
bureau du premier ministre
je pense que le débat est intéressant
c'est le genre de question qui est
d'ailleurs les journalistes se proposent
les médias se posent pour avoir cité à
plusieurs congrès de la fpjq ce genre de
débat où on effectivement ont surtout
critique je suis pas certain qu'ils
aient soulevé par la bonne personne en
plus à la poche d'une campagne
électorale on a l'impression que tous
les textes qui paient qu'un peu la cagd
depuis quelques semaines quelques mois
comme l'a dit martine sont relevés par
des conseillers de françois legault qui
qui se débattre sur les sur les réseaux
sociaux pour être contre si con tout ça
et sa place à un quotidien la presse
dans une drôle de position étant donné
qu'on pourrait aussi se poser cette
question là pour d'autres groupes
médiatiques mais l'on le soulève pour un
seul groupe médiatique parce qu'on est
visiblement pas aimer mais voilà dans la
presse je pense que le débat est
intéressant pas certain que c'est la
bonne personne pour l'initier au québec
vous aurez le temps voulu c'est fini
mais juste un mot oui le des bosses tu
te fais sein de la voir est ce que la
presse pourrait être d'un côté quebecor
trop de l'autre est ce qu'il est ce que
ce ne serait pas sain qui est puis à ce
panel moi j'aime qui a déjà deux partout
passe inquiets des deux côtés peut-être
plus de diversité des bords peut-être à
faire la pj qi moyen mais d'un chef de
cabinet répond stéphanie grammond
à la patrie je trouve ça
particulièrement ironique que la caq
nous accuse d'avoir la pensée unique
parce que je trouve honnêtement que ils
sont rendu tellement fort et on leur
donne 100 députés aux prochaines
élections c'est 80% des sièges quoi il
en voudra encore plus l opposition la
critique c'est sain mais en ce moment on
dirait que le gouvernement dès qu'il ya
une critique ils sont devenu arrogant
alors il traite de martyriser un député
de québec solidaire qui pose des
questions très justifiés sur le sens des
parents qui n'ont pas de places en
garderie il traite de de complotiste un
député libéral qui qui s'objectent là où
au gouvernement par décret ce qui est
tout à fait légitime
et puis si on revient au monde du
journalisme
monsieur legault pendant la pandémie au
point mais nager et s'est acharnée sur
un journaliste de la gazette qui avait
soulevé le premier pour la question des
problèmes au ch et celle des erreurs et
finalement mais la fpjq notre
association notre association
professionnelle vient de lui décerner un
prix je pense que peut-être la façon des
journalistes de répondre à ce genre
d'attaqués de la part du clan politique
moi je trouve que c'est très malsain de
s'en prendre aux médias des médias c'est
très important en démocratie je pense
qu'il faut le rappeler est en ce moment
c'est pas en lançant ce genre d'attaqué
leur en essayant de miner la crédibilité
des journaux qu'on va assainir le débat
je pense que la diversité d'opinion
c'est tout à fait cinq mois à la presse
on le cultive le plus possible dans les
pages débats que je dirige il ya
toujours de la place pour toutes les
opinions entre autres celle de christian
dufour que vous avez souvent au panel
avec qui je suis pas toujours un accord
mais on finit par bravo d'avoir un débat
constructif qui fait avancer la la dives
et la diversité que ce soit le mot
d'ordre pour tout le monde en fait vivre
la diversité d'opinion puis on veut
mieux s'en porter merci ou bavoux 3 à
très bientôt bonne soirée bonsoir
[Musique]